[音楽]
沖縄の
離島に行った時に
たくさんの漂着ゴミを見つけてあ拾わな
きゃって思ったんですけどあれこのゴミ
拾ってどこに持ってくんだろうって思って
で
ホテルに持ってったらまずいよなとか
えこれ本当どうしようゴミ箱ないし
誰かに聞きたいなと思ったけど
島に知ってる人いないし
誰も歩いてないし
あれ私
モチベーションも時間もあるのに
ゴミ一つ拾えないんだって
思ったんですよあでもこの時に
島の人に
ゴミの捨て方を
習うことができたりとかなんかちょっとお
手伝いしてもらえたらこの時の旅って全然
違ったもんになったんじゃないかなって
思ってまた
来るねーとかそういうような何だろうな
まあ友情とまではいかなくてもそういう
あったかい思い出ができたんじゃないかな
とかで私ももっと
島との心の距離が近くなって
島のファンになったりとかそういう
島との心の距離が近くなるって
きっと誰かに何かをやってもらったとか
自分が楽しかったってだけじゃなくて自分
も何か
還元することができたなとか
島のために何かできたで思ったりとかその
向こう側にちゃんと受け手がいて
ありがとうって言ってくれる人がいたりと
かなんかそういうコミュニケーションが
生まれたらもっとあったかい旅になったん
じゃないかなってでそれがきっかけでこの
お金を払ってゴミを拾うっていう
プロジェクトが始まりましたでこの
プロジェクトのルールは簡単で
各種のパートナーと呼ばれるお店とかそう
いうところに行って500円を払って
グッズをレンタルしますそして分別ルール
を習って
ゴミ拾いをしてこのゴミをパートナーさん
のところにグッズと一緒にお返ししてで
パートナーさんが
地域のルールに沿ってゴミ出しをしてくれ
ます
実はボランティアのゴミ拾いってすごく
複雑になるケースがあって
ほとんどの
地域では
ボランティアのゴミ拾いは
勝手にしてるんじゃなくて
地域の自治体としっかり連携をとって
地域の自治体に手続きしないといけないん
ですね
例えば
役場に
電話をして
ゴミ拾いたいんですけどって言ったら
申請書書きに来てくださいとかで
申請書いたらここにゴミをどこどこに持っ
て行ってくださいとか分別はこうですよと
分別間違ってたら
持ってきませんよとか何時までなんとか
センターに持ってってねとかそういう
いろんなルールがあるんですけど
自治体に
ゴミを拾いたいんですっていう
受付をしても
塩対応されることもあるんですね
せっかくあのこの地域のためになりたいん
で
ゴミ拾いみたいにすって言っても結構面倒
くさがられるケースっていうのが
よくあってでもその
実情にはその地域が本当に
ゴミで
困ってたりとか
役場の人数が少なくて回らないとかそう
いう事情があったりします
でも
せっかくの
この年のために何かしたいっていう思いの
人がそういう対応されたら
悲しいじゃないですか
自治体に
受付とかを
せず
ゴミを拾って
例えばビーチのそばに置いてっちゃったり
とかあと雑木林に置いてっちゃったりとか
でもこれは全員でここにおけばこの地域の
人が見つけて持ってってくれるよねって
きっと地域の人は
喜んでくれるでそう思って
置いてっちゃうんですけどでもこれって何
もないところにいきなりゴミ捨て場ができ
た
みたいに見えちゃうんですねなのでそこに
どんどんゴミがやってきてですね
新しいゴミ捨て場だって言ってでどんどん
運営されてないゴミが増えて増えてでそう
いう原因になってしまうっていうケースが
とっても多くてだけどこの地元の人を通し
て受付ができるこのお金を払って
ゴミを拾うっていうプロジェクトをですね
活用するとそういう問題がなくなるんです
ねでいうよりも地域のために何かしたいっ
ていう人が可視化できてそれに地域のため
に何かやってくれる人を
歓迎したいっていう人も可視化できてそこ
に暮らしてる人たちではなくてその外から
来た人もこの地域のために何かできるんだ
よしかも簡単にそんな時間もかけずに
できるんだよっていうそういう取り組みが
広がるとたくさんのところで
優しさの循環が
広まって
豊かな社会になっていくんじゃないかなと
思っています